c'est un nouveau samedi mais comme à
chaque fois en france depuis des
semaines ce jour est l'occasion pour les
opposants pas sanitaire de se mobiliser
à plusieurs rassemblements prévus à
travers toute la france dont à paris
celui sur appels du président à des
patriotes florian philippot cortège en
cours ou dans les rues de la capitale
n'ont ni rejoint de suite notre reporter
lui qu'elle dit
bon luc alors est-ce que l'appel à
manifester de florian philippot a été
entendu
oui absolument malgré l'appui et malgré
le fait que nous soyons en période de
vacances ce qui sans doute a influé sur
l'affluence de cette manifestation mais
ces militants sont toujours déterminés
comme tous les samedis depuis le 12
juillet depuis les annonces des manuels
macro d'étendre le pass sanitaire le
parti des patriotes avaient appelé à une
manifestation mercredi devant le sénat
alors que le texte allait être
réexaminée les sénateurs ont voté un
texte allégé par rapport à la version de
l'assemblée nationale et froid qui se
mettent d'accord en commission mixte
paritaire mais pour ces manifestants peu
importe en vérité ils veulent la
réouverture totale du pays et un certain
nombre d'entre eux ont peu confiance
dans la classe politique selon eux ils
n'ont jamais respecté les délais je vous
propose de les écouter
c'est la discrimination c'est vraiment
un apartheid
ça va pas du tout il ya quand même des
gens en france je sais pas combien on
est à ne pas vouloir se faire injecter
parce que pour moi c'est pas un vaccin
et
de ce fait on peut plus aller ne
serait-ce que prendre un café au café
les les
les gens les soignants qui sont exclues
de leur boulot mais jusqu'où ça va aller
jusqu'où on va où est ce qu'on va
exactement pour défendre nos soignants
et non soignants qui sont
malheureusement
certains sont non vaccinés et son mythe
2 me de côté et je trouve ça totalement
injuste et injustifiée l'opposition
sentant venir les élections commencent à
préparer un peu ses arrières et commence
à se dire bon il faut qu'on satisfasse
quand même un petit peu une partie de la
population en minimisant un petit peu le
grabuge faits par le gouvernement pour
avoir l'air de s'en démarquer un peu
mais pour pouvoir récolter des des votes
voilà en fait pour moi c'est c'est très
électoraliste et c'est pas vraiment dans
un souci
objectif du bien du peuple et de notre
pays cette semaine nous avons appris
d'après une étude de jean françois
delfraissy le président du conseil
scientifique qu environ 20 % des lits
n'était pas disponible dans les hôpitaux
en raison du manque de personnel le
gouvernement veut vérifier ce chiffre
avec une étude plus poussée mais pour
florian philippot tout ça est cousu de
fil blanc c'est la résultante d'années
de suppressions de lits à l'hôpital et
aussi de l'obligation vaccinale des
soignants qui a engendré un certain
nombre de suspensions je vous propose
d'écouter ce qui nous a dit
discret relie sur cinq à l'hôpital est
fermée faute le soignant et b ont dit
non non je suis pas certain de ce
chiffre au doigt mouillé comme ça donc
là bien une enquête sur les enquêtes
dans la réalité c'est qu'effectivement
les plots pital est dans un état
pitoyable c'est cent mille ni fermée
depuis 1993 donnant de l'union
européenne chaque année et ceux qui font
semblant de découvrir aujourd'hui sont
des hypocrites nous le disons chaque
année l'union européenne fait permet les
lits et les gouvernements français au
pays ce maquereau avec l'an dernier on a
permet 5700 ligne chiffres officiels de
la drees les à la santé plus que depuis
2013 revoit
la semaine dernière il y avait eu selon
le ministère de l'intérieur quarante
mille personnes environ dans les rues de
france contre le pass sanitaire hésitait
73000 selon le collectif militant le
nombre joindre des manifestants qui
continuent de scander liberté en
manifestation ils veulent la réouverture
totale du pays
merci à lucas pour toutes ces précisions